well here we are a few months into 2014
and still just a few months into the new
consul cycle one argument I keep hearing
over and over again for PC gamers is why
would you buy a next-gen console when
you can just build a PC for the same
cost and get better performance well I'm
not entirely convinced that that's
something you can do so well myself and
my colleague Mark Walden in the UK are
going to do is we're going to build a PC
for the same cost as an Xbox one in the
highest tax state United States with a
budget of about $550 we run to buy every
component you need including you know
GPU CPU mouse keyboard and windows and
see if you can actually build a PC that
will perform better than a next-gen
console without breaking your budget
here are the parts we're working with
the most obvious part to go for is the
operating system first although I have a
personal aversion to the Metro user
interface I decided to go with Windows 8
because there's a better chance
Microsoft will support it further into
the future than Windows 7 it's easy to
go overboard on a mouse but as long as
it tracks movement and has two buttons
and a scroll wheel I should be able to
play all games without a problem
I also shied away from wasting money on
a keyboard by avoiding unnecessary
features again I opted for a Rosewall
product that's functional enough to get
the job done my choice of a motherboard
is based on a few key factors first it
had to support Intel's LGA 1155 CPU
socket so that I could have a wide range
of new processors to choose from
secondly it had to feature a PCI Express
3.0 slot to ensure wasn't bottlenecking
and graphics card biostar is age 61 mg
v3 satisfied both of these needs
choosing this board came with the cost
of a few features but on the plus side
it was cheap and the micro ATX form
factor meant I could build a relatively
small machine to boot
once I established that I was building a
machine around a micro ATX board I
searched for a small and cheap case and
luckily enough I found one that came
paired with a 300 watt power supply most
gaming pcs require a bit more juice to
power high-end CPUs and GPUs but I'm
building on the cheap Nvidia's GTX 750
Ti is a mighty card for 160 bucks from
EVGA and it doesn't draw too much power
which means it'll work nicely with my
cheap power supply GPUs are the most
important item in a gaming PC build and
even though I would have liked to spent
a little bit more money on a stronger
card I couldn't really spend any more
given my budget most people default to
Intel's Core line of CPUs and building a
PC but again I'm on a budget and so long
as I have a few cores to play with I
should be in good enough shape plus it
was cheap at only $80 choosing Ram was
easy
for most of the games all detesting I
needed at least four gigabytes I don't
need it to be particularly fast though I
opted for two sticks instead of one in
order to take advantage of two memory
channels for increased bandwidth the
final piece of the puzzle is the hard
drive Western Digital blue drives are
inexpensive and reliable and I was able
to purchase a serial ata hard drive with
500 gigabytes of storage while
ultimately staying below my budget all
right that's it for the parts let's put
this PC together alright we were working
with some cramped space inside of this
little box and cable management is
almost non-existent given the
limitations of such a cheap kit but
we've got it all put together let's see
how it works with assassin's creed for
Assassin's Creed 4 proved to be the most
taxing game of the bunch forcing me to
disable motion blur ambient occlusion
and volumetric fog but it's still
performed admirably compared to the Xbox
one version rendered at 900 P and 30
frames per second frame rates on the PC
took the most noticeable dive during
synchronization points but it still
perform as good as or better than the
PlayStation 4 version which is rendered
at a fixed 30 frames per second at 1080p
after struggling to push Assassin's
Creed for his graphical settings it was
great to see our PC handle thief with
such ease granted we weren't able to max
out the settings but the game looked
great on high and maintain 60 frames per
second at 1080p blowing volt consoles
out of the water
apart from lowering a few settings that
were found attacks the CPU such as
impact marks and ragdoll physics
titanfall ran beautifully at 1080p on
high settings compared to the Xbox one
at 792p we had to disable anti-aliasing
in order to achieve high frame rates but
as a result the game hovered between 50
and 60 frames per second during normal
play and around 45 seconds during scenes
with exceptionally long draw distances
before our tests I expected battlefield
4 to be the most taxing game of the lot
but as it turned out we were able to
keep most settings on high without the
framerate dipping below 40 again we had
to avoid flourishes such as ambient
occlusion but like the rest of the games
in our test it still looked better
overall than its console counterparts
all right I admit it
I was skeptical going into this
challenge but the result speak for
themselves for $550 the highest cost of
an Xbox ball in the United States we've
built an Intel Nvidia based PC that
outperforms both the PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one in cross-platform games and if
we had a little bit more money we could
have done just a few components would
have made a much larger difference and
it goes without saying PC gaming library
is huge and we think of all the other
things a PC can do that consoles can't
do the value speaks for itself
but as it stands from a gaming
perspective we've built a PC that
outperforms both next-gen consoles for
the highest price of the Xbox point for
GameSpot I'm Peter Brown see you next
time